my mother used to get so angry because I
would she would ground me for something
that dear a room and I recover my room
she'd get so mad because I'd sit in
there for hours and just have a great
time
you know I he's sitting in there go et
caught up with Jim on set of his first
leading project the short-lived TV
series the duck factory back in 1984
after the series ended Jim was on the
hit series in living color but his major
breakout leading role came a decade
later with Ace Ventura pet detective
I've chosen she was in a path of either
it's gonna be really incredibly
hilarious or completely stupid so you
know if there's no in-between with this
movie I mean the character is way out
your numbers still nine one one alrighty
then they feel braked in a hundred and
seven million dollars at the box office
making Jim a household name look at me
I'm like the Hollywood guy with his
shirt undone to his navel look at this
that same year Jim starred in another
box-office hit the mask the film took in
over three hundred and fifty 1 million
dollars at the box office and cemented
Jim as a leading Hollywood star ok to n
Jim stellar year in 1994 he starred in
yet another huge film and quite possibly
one of his most iconic Dumb and Dumber
while catching up with et onset of the
film
Jim couldn't believe this was his life
it's like somebody else's life I'm
living in a way but it's a it's great
cuz it's just you know it just means I'm
gonna be working a lot so I'm happy
about the film co-starring Jeff Daniels
was another massive success taking in
over two hundred and forty seven million
dollars at the box office and becoming a
comedy classic I'd like to eat her liver
with some farmer beans in a nice bottle
of Chianti
in 1995 Jim started to more hit films
Batman Forever as the Riddler and in the
sequel to Ace Ventura when nature calls
the following year Jim became the Cable
Guy the film was a box-office success
but it's darker tone divided both fans
and critics in 1997 Jim returned to his
comedy roots and starred in the film
liar liar another box-office success
collecting over three hundred and two
million dollars in box office receipts
about Jim's performance in the film late
legendary film critic Roger Ebert said I
am gradually developing a suspicion or
perhaps it's a fear that Jim Carrey is
growing on me in 1998 Jim starred in his
first drama d The Truman Show
good morning morning come on e oh and in
case I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night
the film was another success at the box
office and won Jim his first Golden
Globe in 1999 Jim starred in man on the
moon a biopic of the late Andy Kaufman
and for his role in the film Jim picked
up his second consecutive Golden Globe
Award for Best Actor throughout the
early 2000s Jim's career was in
overdrive starring in many more
box-office hits including me myself and
Irene the iconic holiday film How the
Grinch Stole Christmas Bruce Almighty
and the romantic sci-fi comedy Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind just to
name a few while being honored at the
2004 Canada's Walk of Fame ceremony
Jim shared this message about being
Canadian you don't have to live in
Canada to be in Canada for me Canada
doesn't stop at the 49th parallel it
stops in here and it goes wherever I go
we are all ambassadors to this country
so follow your dreams in 2008 when
Cheryl caught up with Jim for his film
yes-man
she gave him a few gifts from home yeah
in 2011 we caught up with Jim for yet
another film mr. Popper's Penguins where
he told us his early days in Canada came
in handy for the icy feature as soon as
I hit the ice and I put a skate on the
ice and this is true has been true my
whole life since I grew up playing
hockey
I put skate on the ice I am a free man
I am a bird I'm gone I am I am you know
completely free
Jim shared his love for Canada with us
once again when we caught up with him
during the release of the incredible
Burt Wonderstone
I love the City of Toronto I love
there's just something in the air when I
get off a plane I just feel better and I
feel good and I feel elevated and people
are so sweet
and I go out generally around 1 o'clock
in the morning and I and I fly around
the city on my rollerblades you could
probably find some people that have seen
me whizzing past them you know in
September 2018 Jim returned to the small
screen with the Showtime dramedy kidding
projects more and more in my life choose
me when I'm ready the ideas seem to find
me you know the perfect thing so this is
the perfect thing and earlier this year
Sangeeta caught up with Jim to talk
about his movie Sonic the Hedgehog
what's on your bucket list my bucket
list gee I would like to explode into a
ball of light that's one thing you know
until then I just I just want to be I
just want to be a tree full of mangoes I
have a mango tree in my yard and in May
the ground is just covered in these
beautiful red mangoes and I walk out on
the lawn and I pick it up and I open it
and I eat it and it just to me it says
the universe is abundant it's always
trying to give you gifts
[Music]